you
we're shifting the paradigm of materials
creation towards something that's driven
by the end goal so instead of saying
these are all the processes that are
available to us and so the material that
we can expect would have these kinds of
properties we're doing it backwards I
want the material to have a certain
strength a certain weight and based on
that we would like to predict what kind
of architecture what kind of structure
this material is going to have what we
have been doing in our lab is precisely
that we are creating materials that are
very very lightweight that can be up to
ninety nine percent air but yet that
retained their very high stiffness or
high strength of their parent material
the concept that we're taking advantage
of here is very similar to that of the
hard biological systems it's called a
hierarchical design so the concept of
the hierarchical design may be analogous
to comparing the Great Pyramid of Giza
and the Eiffel Tower the pyramid stands
174 meters tall and it weighs 10
megatons now if you compare it to the
Eiffel Tower is 374 metres tall and it
weighs only 5.7 kilotons so there's a
difference in a factor of a thousand
between their weight yet the Eiffel
Tower is very very strong and it's very
very tall so what happened was that
there were elements of architecture
introduced into the design of a pyramid
effectively that allowed it to be
stronger and more lightweight and hence
use a lot less of the material
constituent materials and be a lot
cheaper to construct if we really want
to reduce our reliance on fossil fuels
we really need to figure out a way to
make materials be lighter but yet retain
all the other lucrative structural
properties for example strength and
stiffness there's a huge race right now
to who can make the most efficient solar
cells and they're still not anywhere
near the theoretical limit imagine if
you could take a variety of different
modules solar cell modules that are very
small so macroscopically it will appear
like a flat sheet and so it'll be a
solar panel just like we would expect
but microscopically it'll actually be a
huge array of individual solar cells and
what that will enable is a much cheaper
production of the solar cells so that
Solar actually has a chance to compete
with the fossil fuels and be utilized as
an alternative viable energy source the
major obstacle to these materials being
inserted into viable technological
applications today is the lack of any
kind of a manufacturable process so we
can't mass-produce them if there was a
way for the universities and the
companies and also the policymakers to
all work together and form these
partnerships it will be very powerful
and we could really start inserting
these into the real world applications
you